welcome to this video yeah this is the
first video of a small serious about the
tournament that I just played on the
really beautiful island of Majorca and
the Mediterranean Sea an island very
well known a Germany at least four four
four big tourism many many tourists from
Germany from from from Britain and so on
but that's also chess on this island
quite remarkably and we we had a
tournament there that started on may may
11th and to last it till last Sunday
Sunday in the eighteenth nine rounds
Swiss system open tournament and yeah
I've been very satisfied with the
results some of you may have seen the
results but what I'm going to do is I'll
do a video on on every round basically
besides gay except except the last one
because it was really a very short game
but all other games were interesting and
worth looking at so I'm starting here
with round one and yes some of you may
not be accustomed to the rules officer
those Swiss system open tournaments and
how is it done in the first round yeah
you have all players of course starting
with zero points so who is going to play
each other it's done with the sorting
all the players by rating and then
basically powering the best player by
rating against the player in the middle
of the field so for example if you have
in this case 200 players which was about
I don't know we were slightly below 200
but let's for argument's sake say it's
200 then the number one seed would play
the number 101 the number two seed
number 200 and 102 and so on so in my
case I will see that 33rd I think I
played the number 133 in the
and in in this case it was a player from
Argentina darvid Lizotte or David Lazar
probably butchering the pronunciation
well he's rated 1857 so in the first
round it's really a case where the
favourites need to to win their games
but it's not happening all the time just
two boards on my left right side the
Grandmaster lost against the night 1900
player it can happen ok let's see what
what happened in this game
my opponent played Eve 4 and of course I
didn't do any preparation here because
you only know the pairing a couple of
minutes before the for the round starts
so I didn't know what to expect really
so I played my usual one e5 and yeah
let's see what happens one in five is
sometimes a bit tricky if you want to
win the game because there are some
lines that are really a bit bit boring
so you need to be aware of those lines
and try to avoid them
okay Knight f3 knight c6 and you should
be 5 the Rui Lopez I play a 6 cm and
played Bishop a4 so no exchange
variation Knight f6 yeah and not
surprisingly he exchanged on this looks
maybe a bit strange why would you play
Bishop a4 first and then trade but
that's not a terribly bad idea in fact
there is another very similar line
castles there should be seven and now
Bishop takes c6 deserve this line this
has in fact gained some popularity in
recent years for example one of the top
English players Luke McShane has used
this to to win many fine games and it's
quite interesting at the point is Black
has committed his knight to f6 which is
in those kind of structures not often
idealist black likes to play f6 so on
this sort of diff
our trade is not bad what my opponent
did is he also took him but in this case
I haven't played Bishop d7 yet so this
is probably a bit less precise but in
the in the game here it does not make
much of a difference the point is he now
plays d3 and of course okay I need to
show briefly he cannot take here after
Queen d4 I get my pawn back easily um he
played d3 but now now e5 is really
hanging so I need to cover it and the
argument against the straight as he did
it is of course Bishop d6 I didn't do
that because what I didn't want to have
is him playing a quick a quick exchange
here I mean this is nothing that I
should fear objectively but I don't want
one straight so was so early against the
weaker player so I played ninety seven
ninety two and again Bishop d6 is a fine
move but I played Bishop d7 just to
avoid further simplifications and now in
this case this position if he castles we
would have transposed to the earlier
line that I showed where castles and
Bishop e7 as flicked in effect this I
think they're the best continuation for
white he played Knight c4 first which is
not not bad f6 and now castles he didn't
castle here but played Queen to e2 which
I didn't like so much this is a bit of a
nothing move it's not doing very much
and llamó you want to castle a short
probably anyway so no reason to to delay
that what wide also could have tried
this to play Knight to h4 this is always
an interesting idea getting the Knight
to f5 yeah an tiem I need to decide what
I want to do if I allow the Knight to f5
there's nothing terrible happening but
this would be again some traits coming
up with maybe
oops not this maybe taking here or
anything
I probably would have strongly
considered to play g6 here just to
control their five square it it looks a
bit artificial but okay I don't want as
mentioned to simplify all him yeah he
played Queen e2 I ever after which I
went to night c5 this is a fairly
typical maneuver what black wants to do
he wants to get the knight to e6 where
it controls the important squares f4 and
d4 another good post for the night would
be c6 yeah like if you look at this
maybe c5 98-96 is the other regrouping
that is is also fine but this was a bit
slow so I went 95 Bishop d2 and night to
e6 so this is what black ones
controlling the important f4d for a
squares where the brakes might happen
with default or wider f4 okay 93 I
didn't get this move but it's not it's
not like leading to big problems but
it's not doing much as well I mean at
play g6 as mentioned I want to prevent
Knight f5 but 93 does not help white
very much the null event age form yeah
probably
intending to play h5 which is not a
total threat at the moment as I have
Knight f4 I am so let's say I play
nothing move h5 this night and fine I'm
getting this but anyway I decided to
just block metas and play h5 so that
there's simply nothing happening on the
Kings side what I want to do in the long
run is to do something like c5 c6 Bishop
d7 and maybe push f5 with the right
timing or playing on the Queen side
those are the ideas and of course I
always want to make sure that his brakes
are not too great
sometimes it's
a good way to play just to to take away
the active play from your opponent and
then your active play is coming
naturally yeah he sort of was fed up
with dealing with NIDA foreign plate g3
for just understandable um okay a5 you
know my plan was to gain some space on
the queenside
and maybe set up with b6 Bishop d7 later
and also this may be a for it was a bit
of a space gain on this move and asking
wide okay what are you going to do next
sometimes it's it's just good to let the
opponent do things and try to react
accordingly yeah well he castles short I
guess the right decision I mean castling
long looks weird but canceling short
also and there are some light-square
weaknesses so all those squares awesome
so something to keep in mind yeah I'm
going to be six I want to play Bishop d7
and c5 the immediate c5 he might have
Knight d5 so I'm playing this in a very
very slower slow manner yeah I think at
this moment the position is still around
equal there is nothing terrible
happening too wide but now we start some
some active play which I'm not sure
about played a3 and yeah here it's an
interesting question black can also play
a for setting up
yeah slight bind on the queenside so the
B part cannot move easily but I didn't
want to do that because a3 really signal
signal signals the intention to play
before and I'm actually glad that there
is something opened in the position so
he went before takes takes and c5 and he
I already felt I have a very good
position as it opens up my Bishop gets
is improved now at the moment it just
looks at the d4 pawn which is safely
protected but this is my change in the
future
with f5 maybe and I get rid of my double
bond which is also quite good news so I
was very satisfied at this moment but it
turns out that the position is not so
bad for white
I was a bit too optimistic at this point
I was not thinking I'm winning or
anything but I thought that I already
should have a slight advantage which is
maybe not the case
he played b5 which is the right choice I
guess taking on c5 would have activated
my my piece is far too much yeah and now
I go 90 form which is a very logical
choice if white is given time he might
play c4 and 95 and this would have been
quite unpleasant so 94 is the right
choice and the main point is that TM he
cannot really avoid the trade of the
knight on d4 he took here she takes and
now my idea and also the reason why I
thought I'm better is the idea is to
isolate the b5 pawn this pawn now is not
protected by another white pawn and
always need some protection by a piece
which is not really desirable or white
play c4 which opens up the position
further so I thought that black should
be really fine here but it turns out
that matters are not so clear the next
moves that he's playing I really thought
during the game that this is a terrible
move but I don't think I can really
confirm this after him after some
analysis he now played 92 which at first
sight admittedly looks really weird
because well where's the night going
those squares are easily protected by
black pawns to e1 does not make much
sense I was completely surprised by the
move I was only expecting Knight c4 as
this is a much more more active post and
Knight c4 is the better move but 92 is
not as terrible as it looks after 94 and
we can look at various lines for example
if black
place Queen d7 trying to to win the pawn
it's quite similar to the game y term
has an additional possibility after this
trade rook a 1 let's say castle sir this
is was attacked
he's got the moon flag rook a7 which
introduces this Knight takes B 6 threat
and we see that the night is just a more
active piece here compared to the knight
being on g2 and it turns out that here
there is some quite some counter play
for white if you look at this for
example Bishop c5 covering the b6 square
there is even the move c3 which is
surprisingly interesting it looks a bit
strange because it opens up this but
there is also something positive
happening for white she's got this
Bishop activated yeah and this isn't a
clear position at all this bishop is
still looking at this protected pawn and
I mean it's probably unclear why it has
this kind of ideas you know it's an
interesting position so this is somewhat
better than the game the Knight to c4
but 92 turns out to be not so terrible
as I thought yeah I think the next move
that I played is a bit a bit inaccurate
I took on a 1 here it's not totally bad
but it seems that maybe Queen d7 is a
bit more precise intending after the
Shaq trade Andrew k12 to play king f7 or
to castle and this is a bit a bit more
precise and should keep like at least a
slight edge
nothing overwhelming but it's what I
probably should have should have done in
the game I mean I mentioned I took and
then played Queen d7 because I thought
that the rook entry on the 7
isn't so dangerous I mean it's not fatal
or anything but I underestimated one
particular movement which we will see
you soon
Ruka a seven and Bishop c8 this is what
I had planned I mean I thought that the
bishop on b7 is not so great anyway
because it always just looks at the pawn
and maybe there are ideas for the bishop
here on the light square so I didn't
mind this retreat too much I just
thought I played Bishop c8 Bishop d6 you
know this played Bishop d6 - Kevin c7
and then just grabbed this pawn and I'm
a pawn up and as everything's nice but I
underestimated one particular idea which
he fortunately did not see here white
should have played c3 and after this
move White has a really decent position
I mean it's probably probably about
equal at least the problem is that what
I completely underestimated is that the
c3 move activates the night this is a
very important feature of the position
if I take now Bishop takes there is this
Knight e3 to d5 idea which now has
gained in strength enormous ly as the
bishop is on c8 and cannot just take the
night off on d5 so on this is not very
convenient it is in fact possible that
Bishop D ATM is the somewhat more
precise move and after let's say takes
Queen takes I'm just covering the CM and
and now maybe castling rook f8 a move
like that um it's not not clear this
position I mean if you look at these
castles iced got 95 mm maybe look if a
Droog f7 or something I mean it's
probably probably about equal
disposition and white can certainly
fight on with confidence it's not
nothing terrible happening
but what unfortunately for me I did not
he did not see the c3 move of this idea
and when death went for f4
this is in fact what I expected but as I
also underestimated the c3 idea but f4
is really getting white into big trouble
the problem is now I played this Bishop
d6 move which I had intended anyway and
now while his King side is so weak g4 h
3 g3 and he does not really gain
anything from f4 while b5 is still
pretty much weak he went f5 sorry rook
e8 first
Ruka at first I cancelled and f5 this
was his idea but the the simple fact is
that it does not lead to anything black
has multiple ways now to to get a great
advantage
I played Queen to to g7 and this
position which is OK the easier way to
play is probably to take on f5 but I
didn't I didn't see that
alright let's say I saw that but I
thought Queen g7 is just as good Queen
here and now Queen f7 more Queen h7
those moves are very very good for white
for black I'm sorry very good for black
the thing is why is this so good for
black I've got the two bishops he's got
very bad pieces especially the knight on
g2 and for example if you if you get
this this position yeah here at first
you think okay let's count at five
against five but black is flat-out
winning as the b-pawn would form this
Bishop d7 and takes on b5 and this pawn
on d5 is totally isolated he has
absolutely no way to to cover it so I'm
winning this pawn and at the end I'm
having the bishop town plus an extra
pawn which is just winning winning
outright I've played Queen d7 this is
about the same I'm just
taking on f5 and well white cannot
really take here Queen g6 look at this
g3 is weak I've got the bishop coming
and I still have Bishop d7 takes b5 so
it's just overwhelming for black he went
oops he went the Queen f3 probably
intending to to play some kind of check
in case I capture I played Bishop d7
however taking was also possible but
this is easier I think I'm playing this
ok here should be seven attacking on b5
and initiating a trade which happened
and now he played c4 yeah and here I
made I made a mistake really because I
played the next move far too quickly on
all the time I was always thinking that
if he plays c4 of course I'm just going
to take it to still be able to win the
b5 pawn
however I mean I captured and it should
win as well but it was easier here to
stop for a moment and then just take on
f5 this is much quicker because what is
the white doing now I mean I was I saw
this move but I thought that Queen h5
was a bit a bit a bit of a problem
threatening Bishop h6 this capture it's
no problem at all as I just play Queen
age 7 and win the pawn this is in fact
very easy win so this was the problem
and if I just had to spend a couple of
seconds more on this I probably would
have seen that f4 is just totally
killing white he cannot take because
Bishop g4 traps the Queen quite funny
and this basically means that I'm
threatening Queen g3 which she cannot
prevent at all white absolutely has no
movie in my next move would be Queen
takes g3 and this would have won very
easily and quickly ok I took and took
here and what I what I didn't really
appreciate and while
is a bit more tricky now is that he has
this move deform and my King position is
it's a bit shaky here on evade there's
nothing really terrible happening but I
felt a bit uncomfortable during the game
because well I kept thinking well I mean
this was like looking like a totally
easy win and now my king is somewhat
uncomfortable but it seems that it's
nothing really terrible happening
well I took them after some thought
Bishop takes please note that the times
he are just given by Isis see by default
it's nothing related to the game the
whole tournament was played at a very
very quick time control we had 19
minutes one and a half hour for the
whole game and a 30-second increment
from move one so this was a really
really quick time control and by the
time we had here in this game move 30 my
opponent was down to very little time
three minutes or something well I had
like 10 or 15 minutes so it was some
rather convenient situation on the clock
in terms of me having as time advantage
but you also don't have yeah well 10
minutes is nice to have if the opponent
has three but so sometimes you wish to
have more to really work out a clean win
and sometimes you simply couldn't do
that it's the time you just need to to
dash out moves yeah here for example I
played g5 which is not terrible but G
takes f five was easier it didn't occur
to me during the game because it opens
up even more but the thing is after he
if he takes here I have this strong move
Bishop d7 and yeah well this is
basically a hopeless endgame against the
the bishops an extra pawn and there are
two protected or two passes connected
pesos and on projected bezels so GTA SF
would have been a bit
easier but I played GT 5 not terrible
but what I wanted to do is to keep the
the King a bit bit safer and Queen cakes
age 5 Bush surgery 3 years is the the
right continuation here now I'm
threatening to take on h4 so he took and
I took with the Queen yeah this is what
I had calculated when I played g5 and I
thought I should be winning probably
true but it's already a bit more tricky
than what's really necessary and we will
see that he will get some chances still
in this game yeah he traded Queens now
and now he made Hillary committed a
mistake
what white should do now is play a play
Knight to e3 covering a 5 and 10 degree
5 getting the Knight to d5 this is the
best continuation now he played Bishop
f6 and the problem is that now I have
Bishop d3 and that will win the e4 pawn
and get to this this type of structure
which is of course very favorable for
black with the two connected passes and
the bishops against the lone f5 pawn so
this this should have been really easy
win now but what I did is is not not too
precise in one moment of course at the
time I also only had very little time on
the clock but still it was a was a
mistake played played this one and now
he went f6 yeah which is not not really
great but this was an alternative to
keep the pawn for a moment but this is
also a winning endgame in the long run
just need to need to be precise you
played f6 the thus the problem with this
move is just just exposes this pawn of
course I cannot take here because check
he at the end will win win my pawns but
it's still such a weakness to spawn that
it's not
amended plate King e6 that's okay Nagi
for Bishop d4
there should be three and here made a
made a mistake really but I looked
something the easiest now is to just
take on e3 and this wins pretty easily
going here and then next take the pawn
that's a very very simple win I pretty
much automatically played the bishops e3
just keeping the bishops there is no I
thought there is no need to trade but it
has a it has a drawback a tactical
drawback which I didn't see at all and
he'd also didn't see it we both didn't
have much time white can now put up some
resistance with the interesting move f7
what's the idea yeah that I did um yeah
well I probably have to take it right
take it and then he plays Bishop f4 and
the interesting point is that if I now
save my C pawn which looks very normal
let's say a play C 5 yes the move from
1985 and here in this position I have
two connected passes but it's also
opposite colored bishops and of course
there are some some setups that that
actually do draw the game against even
two connected passes so this I don't
know it would have been still a bit a
bit tricky to to face in fact it's maybe
an idea to just lettuce in this pawn and
and activate the King Bishop here and
then let's say the bishop back and then
March the beep on to bishops against
against the single night is a win it's
not totally trivial but it is a winner
the long run yeah very very a very tough
this would have been very inconvenient
if he found that but well I didn't have
any time on the clock and played Bishop
c5 and now everything's easy again
Bishop f5 and now I'm just winning the
pawn form for nothing
yeah we had this trade and after king e5
he resigned with bishops of the same
color the two connected passes are a
very very simple win I just go there and
then push the pants quite quite easy to
to win so this wasn't a completely easy
game even at the end there were some
inaccurate moves but it's really tough
sometimes with those very quick time
controls where you need to ya decide
quickly on moves and can sometimes
overlook those kind of resources like
this like this f7 movie which I
completely overlooked and what is really
important is that this kind of endgame
here can be very tricky if we look at
this let's say put put this on the
bottom how is how is black going to win
this yeah I'm controlling this square
and let's say black is advancing here
further okay this is in fact the total
draw like this and this okay so this is
a very stupid way to try when maybe go
here go here something like this for
example white is always keeping c3
covered two times and any breakthrough
with c4 c3 is answered by the the piece
sacrifice on c3 so this for example is a
draw yeah there is absolutely no way to
to get any to make any headway here
black can't try to to go to to run
over to the d3 square let's say like
this maybe here here here and then it's
a bit of a silly place here and yeah no
no you go here and see for an answer
baby should be fun so there are many
drawing ideas against the two connected
passer so would have been very
uncomfortable to face and probably I
would have really needed to needed to to
avoid this and play King e6 EMM and God
knows if I would have won that so a bit
of a soft spot in this game he could
have could have gained some drawing
chances so at the end I started with a
win very important the first rule not to
not to stumble and yeah it was an
interesting interesting game
nevertheless despite the be creating
difference you still you have to work
hard to win those kind of games it's
really a big difference nowadays to to
let's say twenty years ago where those
big rating differences at times really
led to two totally one-sided games it
still can happen but very often the
weaker players can put up some some
stiff resistance as we mentioned just to
to bots on my right side
the Grandmaster was really completely
wiped off the board by 1900 player and
there was no cheating involved or
anything was just just a good game by
the by the weaker player at least on
paper all right I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this first round and I'll be
back just tomorrow with the game from
the second round thanks for watching